what's going on guys Greg Alva here
alright on to episode 5 take shelter of
the defenders so I can only show like 5
to 10 minutes worth of a reaction here
I'll get my quick thoughts of the
episode after I'm done watching it when
I'm completely done with the series of
my friend Andrew from the movie source
channel and I will be doing a full
series review of it but in the meantime
after I watch this I'll just get my
quick thoughts on the episode
what happened to the they're probably
going to the restaurant
[Music]
to some shits about to go down and I can
feel it
I've been enjoying this show man
oh you know he means business when he
takes his hat off
[Music]
this guy
even the restaurant okay
[Music]
cool transition cool trances
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa madam show
[Music]
[Music]
you're all about to get [ __ ]
you're all about to get [ __ ]
[Music]
you just shoot the other guys and keep
danny alive
oh man doing your thing
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
whoa she was like like Panther fighting
style
[Music]
that won't kick really
boy I just love Charlie Cox
[Music]
don't don't touch her man
oh she went off there's gonna be some
conflict
[Music]
what happened to two black guys fight
each other yeah
[Music]
he's fine he's fine
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's gonna happen
know that you're gonna do all things get
stance about it
[Music]
things are not looking up for Alexandra
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just like you did
Luke is a fluke
[Music]
you masturbated on the way over here
oh because I wish we saw that fight
oh yeah yeah you got the suit man my
initial thoughts on the episode a I'm
happy Matt is back to just being
daredevil again and we're past all that
build-up super cool to do in the suit
the opening fight of this episode is
really cool I mean the hallway fight to
me was kind of cooler but it might have
been just because it was the first time
they were fighting together moving the
choreography gets more impressive you
know like daredevil season 1 and season
2 had some fight choreography that was
incredibly impressive and I'm hoping
that the defender says at least that one
episode were like that was a very sick
memorable fight on that little moment
when Matt was getting through to Elektra
and you know because he knows who she is
was effective she hits the Japanese dude
it's a predictable part of the show of
course you know like Matt be like I know
who you aren't electro signed a question
who she really is it's a predictable
element of the show but I'm glad it's
here I like all these elements of
Alexandra failing to get a great control
over Elektra and Elektra is unsure
whether or not she should trust
Alexandra which makes me start thinking
that maybe by the final episode maybe
like the last twenty to ten minutes of
the show that Elektra is gonna be the
one who kills Alexandra in the end I'm
hoping she does you know I love Elektra
in daredevil season 2 I've mentioned
that before and I would like to see
aspects of her personality from that
series brought back here instead of her
just being you know evil robotic black
sky and even though Alexandra has power
over Elektra
I think Electra's pretty much gonna get
to a point where she realized how much
more powerful
she actually is then Alexandra and it's
becoming pretty apparent that Sigourney
Weaver knows that too and I keep hopping
back and forth with reason saying
Sigourney Weaver now examine I think the
Kudo coming back is a pretty good
inclusion of the show I just hope it
doesn't become repetitive of what we
already saw an iron fist with him
because I felt that story line between
bakudo and Colleen wing was wrapped up
pretty well and I know that I said in my
first review of the first couple
episodes of this show that the dynamics
between Karen Paige and Matt Murdock
having tension with each other felt a
little repetitive but the conversation
matt has with her about hiding out there
were a couple moments there that I
genuinely appreciate it all she wants is
for Matt to own up to what he does why
he's doing and all those things and when
he does do that in the conversation
there's a moment there that Deborah Ann
Woll she gives a specific look to him
that shows a sense of understanding and
respect and of an appreciation just for
him owning us so in a way I felt it
furthered their relationship I
absolutely love seeing those shots in
the one room in the police station we're
all the main supporting characters from
all these shows are in one room because
a big part of the four main shows are
the supporting characters for the main
protagonist and I do appreciate that the
defenders show is going out of its way
to include all these guys as well more
than just the four main title characters
and seeing them all in the same room was
just you know that's fanservice and I
loved it I loved the fanservice moment
there but it's not just fanservice
because it also made sense for all of
them to be hiding out there and after a
lecturer visited Matt's apartment I've
my thoughts of her killing Alexandra
were just like yeah she's probably gonna
do it and all the moments with I I think
the guys name is someone so honest a
bond a black guy is one of the main
fingers of the hand I thought were
really good his fighting style was
awesome to kind of reminding me of Black
Panthers fighting style a little bit and
him getting under their skin was a great
moment revealing just how much he knows
about some of these guys was very
effective except I know he doesn't speak
about Matt Murdock I don't think he does
which makes Matt's reasoning for
constantly wearing a mask even more
significant because in the last episode
I was like - you need to wear a mask but
because he wears the mask very
intentionally it's like this is exactly
why the dude wears the mask
everybody gets take cutoff that was a
super classic cool stick moment you
could say there's this show
take a stick shift alright thanks for
watching I'm gonna watch one more
episode right now I like to spread these
out you know as much as people love the
binge watching format I like to like
watch two to three at a time absorb it
then wait like another day or two but if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
click that notification bell follow me
at the Greg alb on insta and Twitter we
also have real reject social media and
of course become a patron eject today if
you haven't become one over at patreon